Continuing in al-Wajiz fi Kitab as-Salah
abwab al-mawaqit
And we have completed all of the times
in which a person is to pray and the
times in which it is prohibited upon a
person to pray.
And now the author transitions into
a similar issue.
And that is the places of prayer.
Where is it prohibited to pray? Where?
We've discussed when it's prohibited to
pray.
We've discussed when it is obligatory to
Now the author takes us into where it is
prohibited to pray.
Now notice how he talks about where it's
But he doesn't have a chapter regarding
where is permissible to pray.
Because everywhere is permissible to
pray.
And
[Arabic recitation]
anhu
narrates that the Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wasallam says
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
five things I have been given no other
prophet before me was given.
And one of those five, he says, "And the
entire earth has been made a place for
prayer and a place that is potentially
purifying for his prayer. So, any person
from my nation whom the time of prayer
subdues,
then wherever he is, he has at his
he has at his disposal the place to
pray and he has a method of
purification,
which means a person may make wudu with
any water anywhere and if they have no
water, then with dust with a site. And a
person may pray anywhere, but there are
a couple of exceptions from this
generality.
[Silence]
He says here,
he mentions a narration in Sahih Muslim
on the authority of Abu Hurayrah, very
similar to the narration of Jabir that I
just mentioned,
that the messenger of Allah sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
said, "I have been
given virtue and esteem over the rest of
all of the prophets with six things."
He says, "I have been given the most
comprehensive of words." Meaning the
Quran, the Sunnah,
they are
very concise but most comprehensive.
He says, "And I have been given
victory." Meaning see him, his
companions, his armies, right? Have been
given victory by way of striking terror
into the hearts of their enemies.
And the
[Arabic recitation]
the spoils of war have been made lawful
for me." Meaning for him and his
his nation.
And the entirety of the earth has been
made a purifying place and a place for
prayer for me and my nation. And I have
been sent to all of the creation,
meaning the human being and the
jinnkind. And finally,
prophethood has been ended with me. I am
the seal of the prophets." This
narration is in Sahih Muslim.
So, all of the earth, everywhere, every
place has been made a lawful,
permissible praise place
for me to pray.
Except for a couple of places mentioned
in the following narrations.
[Silence]
On the authority of Jundub ibn Abdullah
al-Bajali, he says, "I heard the
messenger of Allah salallahu alayhi
wasallam saying 5 days before his death,
indeed
those who preceded you all, meaning the
nations that came before you, before the
Muslimin, the previous nations, they
used to and they made a habit and a
tradition of
making the
grave sites of their prophets and the
grave sites of their righteous
as places of prayer."
And notice he says masajid.
The masjid in the Arabic language
and even in the Quran,
it is used to refer
to a place dedicated to salah,
this building. This is a masjid.
It's used to refer to any place a person
prays. This is a masjid.
Anywhere a person prays, this is their
masjid at the moment, meaning it's the
place where they are making sujud,
meaning making salah.
And also the word masjid
and masajid is used to refer to the
places on the body that the person makes
sujud with.
Three things.
Al-masjid in the Arabic language, in the
Quran,
in the Sunnah,
when this word is used, it's used to
refer to one of three things or
sometimes all of three things.
Number one,
the dedicated buildings for prayer, for
salah, a masjid. That's what usually
comes into our mind when we say masjid.
Number two, any place a person prays.
For that time, that is its masjid. Like
in the narration we just mentioned.
Number three, the places of sujud on the
body.
So, Allah says, "Wa annal masajida
lillah."
He says in Surat
Al-Jinn,
"That the masajid, plural for masjid,
belong to Allah."
"Fala tad'u ma'a Allahi ahada." So, do
not worship along with Allah anyone.
What does this verse mean? The masajid
belong to Allah.
What does it mean?
The masajid belong to Allah.
Which one of those meanings?
All of the three.
Because masjid is used to refer to what?
Three things.
Number one,
the the building that is the masjid.
Number two,
any place a person prays. That's a
masjid. Number three,
the the body parts that are used to make
sujud. This is called a masjid.
So, when Allah says the masajid belong
to Allah,"
it means all of these three. The masjid
that is the building, any place on the
earth that you make salah,
and
the body parts you use to make sujud.
All of these are a masjid. They belong
to Allah.
Right? So, do not worship along with
Allah anyone else.
And so, here
in this narration, the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam says
that
"Those nations that preceded you,
they
would take
and dedicate and designate the grave
sites of their prophets and righteous,
the saints, the righteous people.
Someone that's known for righteousness
and dies.
Salihim.
They would take the grave sites of their
prophets, their messengers, their
righteous, and they would dedicate them
as places of worship."
Which means what? Which means the first
two meanings. Either they would go to
worship Allah at the grave site,
or they would actually build a building,
a masjid, and make the grave in the
masjid as part of the place of worship.
Do you understand? If a person were to
go to any grave,
and then proceed to worship Allah there
at that grave,
right?
This person has taken that grave site as
a place of worship, as a masjid.
That's why it is impermissible to do
anything at the grave site except what
is in the Sunnah of the Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
The Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
would make dua there
for the deceased. He would convey a
salaam to the deceased.
Et cetera. And because death is so scary
and everybody is so scared to death,
you'll find that so many innovations
are
brewed
and cooked up at the gravesite.
Everyone who has someone that dies, that
person that is close to them,
that person is special. They need
special
worship to honor them.
What is that special worship?
Well, whatever comes to your mind at the
moment. Whatever you you know, whatever
you feel like. I want to make adhan
at the at the gravesite. I want to
go into the grave and lay in there
before that person goes in and and spend
some time in there. Many innovations
have been
created in
this area because of the nature of
death, all right? It's natural,
but just because something may be
somewhat expected doesn't mean that it
is acceptable. We will continue this
[Arabic recitation]